welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we finally have
some amazing news for the killer show
mind hunters returned throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about mine under
season 2 including its release state
themes cast and more there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't seen any
of season one yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way
thank you for clicking the video I hope
you enjoy it now let's get into my
breakdown of mind hunters season 2 okay
so first things first mind hunters
season 2 will be released on the 16th of
August worldwide with all episodes
dropping on the same day in typical
Netflix fashion season 2 was
commissioned even before season 1 had
been released so it's clear that Netflix
are very confident in the property and
where it's going but wise season 2 is
set to be centered around two big crimes
with the first being the Atlanta child
murders which took place between 1979
and 1981 the brutal attacks claimed the
lives of at least 21 people and whilst
David Fincher initially said that you
could probably set three seasons around
the killings it seems that we're just
getting the one for the time being the
case itself was eventually solved and
the killer was later revealed to be
Wayne Williams a 23 year old Atlanta
native it's unclear whether this will
take up the first part of the season or
run side by side with the second more
infamous pot setting which are now
getting to that is the murders carried
out by Charles Manson and his cult in
1969 Damon Harryman is set to play the
infamous killer which is quite funny as
he's also been cast as Manson in Quentin
Tarantino's upcoming movie Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood so yeah a Hobie
doesn't mind being typecast anyway the
tape murders which Manson's followers
carried out took place on August the 8th
which just so happens to be my birthday
so yeah bad day in general and it will
no doubt be a massively shocking part of
the show the crime was carried out by
four of Manson's followers who invaded
the home of Roman Polanski and Sharon
Tate they killed five people including
Tate who was eight months pregnant at
the time though Polanski was not at the
residue
when the crimes were carried out this
will of course be another massive part
of the show and it seems like the season
will stretch the time setting slightly
by placing both in the same time period
even though they happened almost a
decade apart it's unclear whether the
BTK killer that was teased in the
initial season will be making a return
as in real-life serial killer Dennis
Rader was not caught until the 2000s and
the act of the plays him is nowhere to
be found in any of the cast lists he was
not active between 1977 and 1985 so the
show might perhaps hint at him in this
season and set things up in place for
further down the line with the
showrunner stating that they were eyeing
up five seasons returning to the show is
Jonathan Groff who will once again be
playing Holden Ford IMDB also lists Bill
tenchu is based on real-life criminal
psychologist Robert Ressler returning
with a Natur playing dr. Wendy Carr who
is loosely based on an wahlberg Burgess
behind the scenes David Fincher is back
in the director's chair and he will be
heading up both the premiere and the
finale all in all it's setting up for
another great season and fans of the
macabre with a fascination for serial
killers will definitely find a lot to
like here
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on mind hunter season 2 and if you're
excited for it comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my stranger things season 4
predictions video which would be linked
at the end I go over all of the things I
think will happen in the upcoming season
and give the evidence to support it so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more I'll leave that
link at the end and hopefully I'll see
you over there after this I also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of Avengers endgame on
blu-ray to one lucky winner and all you
have to do is like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on mine hunter in
the comment section below the word it'll
be chosen at random on August the 10th
and the blu-ray will be shipped out from
then - ever gets the prize best of luck
to everyone who takes part and thanks
again for checking out the video
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]